are we going to see you tell the story
in black panther 2 will we see you in
that sequel what can we expect will you
be in it because i'm hearing conflicting
reports here i'm waiting why why i was
doing nope i was filming notes
i was always in prep and then the call
came and then it wasn't able to to do it
and you know like it's love man but also
like i i mean i've heard things and i
know that they're gonna do chad
an incredible incredible incredible
credible service so that's what that's
what i really care about and i can't
wait to watch it did you read the script
at least
i had things man i caught you know i
know i heard from you
did you read the script i heard things
you heard things yeah well you can tell
me off cam we can just chat about this
on the kind of can i do that can i do
that
i can do that will it will i yes you
will
yeah that's a good question
[Applause]
[Music]
and talk to me about jupiter's claim
this is uh the set recreated on the
universal lot right and here you guys
are making history with this being here
at universal yeah it's amazing i think
it's the first time that they've done it
for a film that hasn't come out yet so
it's pretty cool next level jordan peel
stuff but yeah jupiter's claim it has a
really cool story in nope i don't want
to give too much away about it but
stephen ewan has a great connection to
this place and i think people are going
to like the universe that it explores
at the end as well oh yeah
i mean
that was a little emerald right there
you'll see her pop out just a dash just
a dash i mean there is nothing like the
mind and the world of jordan peel and
here you are you're getting ready to
work with you've worked with him now
this is your second time on a film
you're working with him in the third
film behind the scenes
looking like some good stuff but he has
called you
his favorite actor ultimate favorite
actor what does it mean to hear that
from him and then the people look at
them everybody on the tram
that's so funny that's what they're
gonna do they're gonna roll through
jupiter's flame just like that y'all so
cool oh my gosh but talk to me about you
know jordan's been laying on these
accolades about you singing he's good
he's going on true he's going up
i mean you have to kind of it's i mean
it's it's flattering in this like
because i respect him so much as a
filmmaker and as a voice so and i'm
sorry as an actor you get like joel's an
incredible actor yeah you know so it's
um but like with all compliments like
you accept it love and then that cool
the work like don't let it get to you
mm-hmm you mean because yeah
you can't you can't do anything with
that you know like i'm gonna like in
your performance like
this
you're like no i'm playing this guy this
is i'm trying to talk to you and this is
what uh yeah
you just have such a cool and chill
approach
i mean truly you just become you invite
and you do as well kiki and you're like
you're paced you're so fast
whoa she's a bundle of energy um so for
you what was it like taking part and now
the second time with phil you know
really cool because the first time that
we did it was just a quick little sketch
for um
so this time around obviously we'd be
spending more time together and this is
such a greater scale uh than anything
i've ever done and i think it was also a
jump for him just in terms of all the
effects and you know filming on imax
cameras and we have all this time and
space to really do everything that we
want you know um and so it was just
awesome and also i love my character
like you said emerald has so many
different aspects to her yeah she starts
off you know in this jester personality
and then slowly plays in the orphan
archetype the way that she's written is
just so uh skillfully so i was excited
to to play her and do her justice really
and it was so good because i felt like i
was so believing we've got this
brother-sister thing going on because
really that's the central part of this
of this story i focus around
focuses on this brother and sister so
how did you guys capture that
relationship between one another it's
just like it's just not true i mean like
you're such a man i love it
because it's just like kiki's a very
generous performance yeah she's very
open so like you i always feel like when
the scene she wants the best for me and
i want the best for her and so and then
we tried to try and we both put in the
character first as opposed to ourselves
so then they said what makes sense for
this scene i was like how do we buy
about how do we and we really cared
about making like joyous moments between
them you know like and having those
moments where uh brother and sister or
brother my brother or sister citadel
that's like me right yeah that's like me
and so that's a i think that's just how
it came out and i love it because like
we do it is a horror movie you know
thrilling sci-fi aspects to it but it's
got some comedy
and it also has joy which i love seeing
an element of joy that i wasn't
expecting from a horror film
um and especially focusing on two black
leads yeah in a horror film you know
but we see that joy here and i i love
seeing that but honestly how does it
feel or how do you portray being scared
poor thriller you know you've gotta you
gotta act terrified from time to time so
where does your mind go how do you get
yourself scared without looking too
cheesy you know right
it's like it's like how do i look scared
and how do i look scared with something
that i probably am never going to
encounter and be scared by right you
know you know how you're going to be
scared if somebody says boo or you know
if you see you know a bug in your house
but like when you're talking about a
spectacle that the one that's in this
movie i don't even know what i would
think so yeah you play around a little
bit you know you have fun and luckily
jordan gave us the space to have a
couple of different reactions to what it
was we were seeing but i think it's just
trying to be as true as you can to the
moment and also be diverse you know you
don't want to just scream i remind you
what what else would you do sometimes
you're speechless or in daniel's case no
that was i
laughed out loud in that moment so so
good um we've got nope coming from y'all
which fans are going to love as they
always do with jordan's films and with
the two of you at the lead of it but
light year for you missy oh yeah in
addition to nope i mean you got
everything going on right now and i hear
you're you're crafting your career after
little dashes of moguls a little bit of
oprah a little bit of ron howard is that
how you're rolling these days yeah i
mean i definitely admire oprah for what
she's able to do as a personality as a
brand and then obviously ron howard who
also was a child star you know so to be
able to work from being a kid and then
get more behind the camera i think
that's i think that's the goal for all
of us you know as actors to be able to
have the opportunity to tell stories in
a different way